Now things should become challenging.
I ask you to program the mode of a data set.
Of course, data sets can have multiple modes.
I just extended mine to have 3 times the element 5.
Let's assume for now if you have multiple modes
you can return either one; I don't care.
But if it's unique, I want the correct mode.
So this is entirely nontrivial for programming,
and it's a real challenge.
This is what makes this class fun.
When you hit print mode of this data set
then I want it to return 5.
Now some hints: There are many different ways to implement it
using complex data structures such as sets,
but at the minimum for a simple solution,
you should know what a for loop is,
what an if statement is,
and then there's a beautiful function
called "data.count."
You give it an argument--like this case the number 5--
and it returns to you how often this specific number occurs
in the data over here--three times for number 5.
If you were to give it 6 as an argument,
it doesn't occur at all,
the result would now be zero.
So my solution has a funny "for" notation.
For variable "i" in the range of the length of data.
Len(data), we know, is the number of elements.
There's 7 over here, so it would give me 7.
Range turns this into a list from zero to six of indices into the data,
and then the for loop goes to these indices.
That's one way to access each element in the data set sequentially.
Now the count thing allows me to count how often each element occurs.
So if you took my data--took the i'th data item--
then what this thing gives me--
this funny thing it gives me.
How often inside this function do I see that specific number
that is the i'th number in the original list?
I leave it at this. This is not a trivial question.
If you get stuck, you might go to the web
and read up on for, on count, on if statements.
So here is the code, and good luck programming it.